il ya cent ans jour pour jour mouret
victor hugo l'écrivain poète et homme
politique pensait que le vendredi est un
jour néfaste il est mort le vendredi 22
mai 1885 l'assemblée de l'époque dans
laquelle il ne comptait pas que des amis
lui a voté pourtant à l'unanimité moins
deux voix quand même des funérailles
nationales
aujourd'hui un hommage lui est rendu
dans de nombreux pays du monde comme la
chine et le vietnam
à paris le sénat a honoré sa mémoire et
ce soir le garde des sceaux robert
badinter est redevenu avocat pour
plaider en faveur d'un homme de liberté
c'est en 1848 constituante grand débat
qui commence sur la peine de mort une
couronne à l'après qg s'exclame xviiie
siècle à agboville la torture
this ième siècle l'abolir a sûrement la
peine de mort voyez une scène de tromper
que d'un siège
et le 21ème siècle alors abolira quoi
retraite
écoutez
peut-être
peut-être il introduira une
une autre idée
de la peine mais là vous me permettrez
blanc dure plus le garde des sceaux
prononcer ce soir à la sorbonne à
nommage victor hugo